Welcome back to the show.
Let's get right back to the phones at (617)
830-4750, starting with our color from the
three four, seven area code.
Who's calling today from three, four seven.
Hi, this is daddy's mom home.
Hey Eddie, what's going on?
Um, I was, um, anyway, great man.
I've been watching you for the, I mean, I've
watched you for the last three years.
Thank you.
[inaudible] alright.
Um, my question is if Trump loses in 2020,
don't you think he, his influence on the Republican
Party is gonna be there long as that he's
gone.
[inaudible] I believe you though he will have
the influence of the vote.
Is his base still?
I don't, I mean, I think it's a little bit
more nuanced.
It's not that once Trump is gone, so at some
point Trump's going to be gone.
It could be in 20, 20, could be 20, 24.
Um, I don't think it's that Trump is personally
going to maintain influence over voters.
I just [inaudible]
I think that the Trump effication of the Republican
party is going to persist for a long time.
The idea that it's fine to have, I mean, listen,
George W. Bush was no genius, but with Donald
Trump, the idea that it's fine to have a completely
ignorant person of economics, diplomacy,
[inaudible]
uh, just everything that that's OK.
That it's OK to have candidates that speak
to others in the way that Donald Trump does
that do policy by tweet.
I think those, like the coarsening of the
dialogue is what the effect of Donald Trump
is going to be beyond Trump.
It's not so much that Trump will influence
voters.
It's that he's influenced the Republican Party.
Yeah.
But what if we had this loose network?
Well, that talkative low ones on the slope,
it's possible.
Um, I mean, I dunno.
He's, yeah, he's promoting OAN more and more.
And I wouldn't be surprised to see once Trump
is gone, whenever that is from office, getting
more involved with, uh, with OAN, which he
just seems to be just thrilled with as I predicted
he would be for months ago.
But yeah, maybe he would look at starting
a network.
Maybe not.
I mean, if he gets reelected, he's going to
be almost 80 years old when he's out of office
and maybe he's just going to retire.
Oh, one quick thing.
What are you, what are your thoughts about,
um, Trump's tweet about Fox News today?
Didn't see it.
What'd he say?
Um, he's saying that maybe that they should
go all the way left and we, and maybe pop
the dealership, go to Lan.
Oh, did he, did he actually tweeted that this
week?
Yes.
Did not see that, but not surprised then.
Makes a make I'm doubling down then on what
I just said.
I look, I look forward to your video about
that.
All right.
Thanks.
Really appreciate the call.
Thank you, David.
Take care.
Yep.
Uh